scott disick's got a new girlfriend and
we know just what the kardashians think
about it
yeah et has learned the reality star is
dating kimberly stewart a longtime
friend who also happens to be the
daughter of rock superstar rod stewart
the two have been fueling romance rumors
for a while now spotted on multiple
nights out all captured by the paparazzi
happy birthday
can you confirm your dating
that's the two leaving a restaurant in
santa monica earlier this month holding
hands as they dodged the paths they were
out celebrating kimberly's birthday
happy
birthday you confirm your dating
back in july a source downplayed the
romance telling e.t the two were just
quote close good friends but added scott
would love to settle down one day but
for now he's just dating and having fun
i mean i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day well looks
like laura disick is making kimberly
part of his life's plan our source says
quote things turned romantic toward the
end of may early june
adding quote they are seeing each other
now and it's still casual but they are
both happy
so what does this kardashian family
think
our source promises the family is quote
supportive of scott and the relationship
quote as long as he is happy and healthy
and the kids are good
they want what's best for him
season two is gonna be insanity here we
come this is my good side just to let
you guys know
i feel like i'm becoming my own woman
but i really want to be my own boss
going through what i went through was
incredibly hard i just feel that i'm a
fish and a fishbowl i really feel like i
found my personal confidence
this news comes as hulu dropped an
all-new trailer for season two of the
fam's reality show and scott is m.i.a i
don't understand why i should be left
out the lack of scot in the trailer left
some fans wondering the status of things
between him and the extended kardashian
jinner crew
a topic explored a lot in season one i'm
so sorry that that makes you sad and i'm
not ever trying to leave you out but
what i'm saying is like i should have
texted you but don't worry the fam isn't
ditching scott and he is expected to
appear in season two despite online
speculation that courtney's ex had been
quote excommunicated by the group
after paper magazine posted a report
that said as much momager kris jenner
shut down the idea in the comments
section
saying quote scott will never be
excommunicated from our family he is the
father of my grandchildren and a special
part of our family we love him and not
true
that's right scott is is my brother like
we're basically blood at this point and
so it would be very weird if he wasn't a
part of our family and i don't think
there's ever going to be a day where
he's not a part of our family in some
capacity between his new boo and his
famous fam support scott is well loved
and clearly living his best life happy
birthday
can you confirm your dating
[Music]